Speaker 1: You might remember last week I told you
that Lara Logan, formerly of 60 Minutes, she is a
she is now a right wing conspiracy knight. I hate
to use such titillating and provocative language,
but that is what she is. She appeared on
Newsmax. I played the clip for you. She
delivered a completely unhinged, xenophobic
rant. Essentially her version of white
replacement theory or great replacement
theory. She was banned from Newsmax.
Instead of rethinking some of her ideas and
saying, maybe I was wrong on some of this stuff, I
don't know. She appeared on The Absolute Truth on
Lindell TV with an even crazier conspiracy theory
about children. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: I believe that people
reacted that way is it's all about the children.
The question they don't want us asking is,
where are all the missing children? What happens
to these children? How can hundreds of thousands
of kids go missing in the United States every
year and nobody knows where they are? They just
vanish? I don't think so. Every sex trafficking
ring worldwide knows bring the kids to the United
States that this administration is participating
in the trafficking of kids because they're paying
companies, agencies and nonprofits and church
groups. They're paying them to take these kids.
And this event included the report that
you showed have talked about the blood
of young children being the secret to anti-aging.
Speaker 1: You guys, you know what you just said,
right? Ingesting or injecting the blood of
young, young children as an anti-aging mechanism.
Speaker 2: And why does nobody
ask, where does blood come from?
How do you get the blood of young
children? And does it matter if
the children are younger and younger
and younger? So now you're told. Are
you talking about the blood of babies now?
Speaker 1: No. No one's talking about that,
Lara. You know, at this point, it
genuinely seems like this is someone who.
Should be more on the mental health treatment
side than the delivering opinion publicly side.
You got banned from Newsmax. Newsmax is insane
and what you said was too crazy for Newsmax.
It's time to maybe rethink some of your views,
but unfortunately, and I'm not even kidding, this
is kind of sad because at one point Lara Logan
did some reasonably good journalistic reporting.
She is completely off the deep end in every
way, and I feel bad for her to some degree.
But at the end of the rainbow, for lack of a
better term, I want to have compassion and,
you know, all these different things at the end
of the rainbow. There are so many people in the
United States so delusional and depraved that even
this stuff they hear and they believe. I mean,
who would have thought Cunanan beliefs could
invade one fifth of the Republican Party,
as we learned in a recent poll? And so my instinct
is empathy. And you saying this is someone who's
in a crisis, she needs support, etc.. And also
extremely dangerous because of the things that
she is saying which get followers no matter
how crazy they are. My friends. Subscribe to
the YouTube channel. We are doing our very best
to get to 2 million subscribers. We're at about
1.55. Now we don't even need any new viewers to
get to 2 million because I learned that last month
4.3 million different people watched
videos on our YouTube channel,
and yet only 1.5 million were subscribers.
We already have nearly 3 million additional
viewers. They already watch the content. Some
of them even like it, although some don't.
If just a fraction of you fine folks who watch
but don't subscribe, hit that subscribe button on
YouTube. We could get to 2 million overnight. Do
the thing youtube.com slash The David Pakman Show.
We're going to take maybe the shortest break
in history and be right back with much more.
The David Pakman Show is, of
course, a program supported by
our audience. We don't have some big media company
backing us. We don't have, regardless of what
people email in and say, some rich guy funding the
show. We're primarily funded by you and you can
sign up at join Pacman Dotcom, get a membership,
get the bonus show, get the daily commercial, free
audio and video feeds and the exclusive invites to
the members only town halls. Get all of it and you
can use the coupon code. Big voting 22
to get an absolutely perfect discount.